yeah i've never been so hot and cold at
the same time
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm shawn evans and you're
watching hot ones
it's the show with hot questions and
even hotter wings and today we're joined
by aquafina
she's the golden globe award-winning
actress you know from films like crazy
rich asians and the farewell
her latest project though is the highly
anticipated animated film
ryan the last dragon which opens in
theaters and on disney plus with
premiere access on march 5th
aquafina welcome to the show thank you
thank you for having me
what's your mindset like going into this
10-wing gauntlet here
i feel like everyone like when they come
on hot ones like everyone's a little
scared but like
like i saw this show called champions
and it was on
it's like an episode of netflix where
like they basically compete and they eat
the ghost peppers and then they talk
about this thing that happens to their
stomach after
it's like a lot what is the aftermath
like sean
well you know what it's funny that you
mentioned champions because i actually
know that guy that features uh smoking
ed curry yeah and he's the guy who
he's the guy who did that episode yeah
and uh he actually
makes this hot sauce here at the end so
we'll get the full pucker butt
experience here today aquafina oh
no oh [ __ ]
[Music]
bring it out
wow
[Music]
that's nothing dude so i want to start
by talking about your new film which
tells the story of a lone warrior
tracking down your character sisu as
part of a last-ditch effort to save
humanity
is someone who oscillates between nora
and aquafina
did you feel a special connection in
this film playing the role of a
shape-shifting dragon
oh wow um wow that's a that's a big
metaphor to
my life but yeah i mean thinking about
it now i think that shape-shifting
definitely a duality with sisu and and
also i think in my
own personal life so that's a that's a
really good observation this is maybe an
odd question but i've always been
curious about this
when you're cast to play an animated
character
do they already have the art created for
that character or is there any sort of
reverse engineering after it's been cast
um well i think for me when you
watch sisu you can see
that the animators use my eyes and like
my teeth
i saw maybe sketches of cesium but i
never saw her animated until i recorded
and so that there were lines i think
that's
the really cool thing about doing
voiceovers yeah it's a it's a really
collaborative
uh thing
[Music]
oh this has no little hole this has no
little butthole on the thing
all right let's do it
hmm that's so good i'm reopening that
so having been in close proximity to the
great go 90 experiment
i remember talk with aquafina quite well
you do i do i do because in complex you
know is the go 90 operation was obvious
yes yes right so i remember that whole
thing
what in your opinion makes for a good
talk show interview
and has your experience as a host it all
informed how you approach being a guest
now that you're on the other side of the
table it does all all the time
yeah i think it's uh i think you know
it's not easy being an interviewer
because you have to constantly adapt
yourself to make that other person feel
comfortable as a guest i'm so embedded
in the host mentality that i want to
make the host comfortable too
so it's it just is a if you're already a
pushover it's not a great game
to play i guess is what i'm saying yeah
so i remember when you know the new york
city rap blogs when your music started
breaking on those
and now in recent years you know you're
getting profiled for the cover of vogue
as someone with a foot in both worlds
where do you find your
biggest critics always yourself dude
always
for me like a big problem is that i uh
i i feel like people don't know people
don't know me anymore so that that was
like it would be my personal life that's
like a big thing like i just like
feel like i've went through a lot of
experiences that people assumed were a
certain way
especially later on like when great
stuff started happening so uh
it's always gonna be me no matter what
because no one's really gonna know
what's going on
you know
[Music]
so far really good yeah i could do this
all day
oh again no little butthole so that's
that's what does that mean does that
mean that they're like
they're like rogue like they're the
kombucha people that like
put all the pulp in in this lineup
we are mostly butt holeless actually
that first one so much
that's the problem that's the dangerous
game that's the dangerous game aquafina
when you're playing without a butthole
over here
anyone ever go to the hospital um
chrissy teigen said on the tonight show
that after her episode she went to the
doctor
so that's the only known one that i have
but that happened
wow
um wow so that's the first time it
it kind of yells at you a little bit you
know
aquafina we actually have a curveball
for you on this swing we've called in
an old friend who's been with you since
the release of yellow ranger in the
early campus tours that's right
without further hype building we are
gonna welcome to the show
the host of first we feeds the takeout
john park
aka dumbfounded is here
with a set of questions for aquafina
from memory lane we've had many blurry
nights at karaoke's from k-town la to
32nd
and new york what is your go-to karaoke
song
my go-to karaoke song uh that he
probably is thinking of
is is well we all we all like to do a
little hema
um and uh dreams by fleetwood mac
dumb doesn't also do karaoke everyone
probably sees him as like this like
karaoke guy he doesn't really sing
i think he enjoys being around you know
with the fruit
and whatnot but like i don't think he
actually enjoys like
partaking which is interesting we've
done our fair share of sketchy college
shows
do you have any memorable tour stories
yes
we do can we share them here i don't
really know if that's the best
idea dumb does this thing where he
forgets all the lyrics
and then he'll do a thing where he'll
like let's take it let's take it back
and uh and and blame it on the audience
so he he he would do that but then one
time i think even after he blamed it on
the audience he forgot
he continued to forget touring with dumb
is the best man that was some of the
best times of my life going on tour with
those guys
all right we have one more for you i
remember teaching you a lot of korean
words and you asked me how to say
cat nipples in korean do you still
remember how to say that
i just remember
which means my cat uh don't remember i
don't remember nipples though
[Music]
okay yeah that's talking all right
what's your relationship with hot sauce
i've eaten straight up carolina reapers
before so it's like wherever the ceiling
is
i've hit it and i've survived it so i
think that that gives me some peace of
mind
but do you ever think that you could do
competitive hot sauce eating
no no no those people are crazy like
when we were talking about that show
like i ate one carolina reaper one time
and it
ruined my earth two times actually but
it was like giving yourself food
poisoning for 12 hours
people in those eating contests they'll
eat like 15 or 16. i don't even know how
that's possible
oh man i'm not panicking i'm not i'm
fine
i'm totally i'm chilling dude it's great
yeah so i understand that you come from
a long line of restaurant tours your
great grandfather
he opened a cantonese restaurant in the
1940s in flushing queens and then of
course
your grandmother she ran a restaurant
out in port jefferson
yes how'd you know that
that's cool poor jeff how do you know
about port jeff that's cool because
everybody everybody knows that everybody
knows that and then
there's a part of your life that sounds
like it was almost written for a sitcom
but i know that it's real
you worked at a vegan bodega between
that job
and then working at a very legit
japanese restaurant
which one of those hospitality gigs do
you remember more fondly
uh well i i think i remember them both
but the japanese restaurant
was like like i remember spilling
hot sake onto a woman's coat like a
beaut
like her beautiful coat and she was on
what looked like a first date where she
was uncomfortable to like really yell at
me like to really
go off on me so she kind of held it in
and as i walked away
she went oh my god i've had so many bad
waitresses in new york city
and i just remember hearing that and to
this day like i still really haven't
gotten that out of my head
it still kind of makes me feel like a
really bad for doing that
um so i didn't get i didn't get a lot of
that at the vegan bodega i got more of
that at the japanese restaurant for sure
halfway point okay have you ever met
the right of the copywriter for hot
sauce brands and what are they like
you know before i got this show i was
actually a copywriter
and i have to say that i really respect
hot sauce marketing and branding you
know like
you can have what kind of looks like
cool craft beer labels
and then you have what are like hellish
landscapes of like
fire and brimstone and grim reapers and
skulls
on fire so i think like that kind of
range it offers great opportunity for
like a good
ad person you're right it can go from
like comedy to horror in terms of just
their
that's really cool i never thought about
that because you can't really advertise
anything else
like that i love the bottles like i
almost like
love hot sauce as like a collector's
item put on your shelf thing more than
as a condiment yeah i actually still i
the only thing that i have collectors in
my
actual kitchen at home is is a collab
that hot ones did with uh
with with 88 rising and like that thing
like it's like dragging the clouds
yes i do i like i put it up i don't know
i haven't opened it you're just there
i'm very proud of it too because it's a
cool collab
yeah all right aquafina we have a
recurring segment on our show called
explain that graham where we do a deep
dive on our guest instagram pull
interesting pictures that need more
context
so i'll show you the picture you just
tell us the bigger story you gave a
really touching tribute to lucy lou in
your saturday night live monologue
do you remember the first thing that you
said to her when you guys finally got a
chance to meet
i think it was probably like hey i think
it was just i think it was literally
that i think it was like
well hey whoa what's up uh that's when
you know i'm really nervous when my
spine is in a complete sea and i'm just
like hey
what's up yeah cool i was so nervous to
meet her but she actually has a very
unnerving quality which is
good right i felt the warmth and then i
you know straightened up a little bit so
she was she's really cool my grandma
gave me these
because she knew i was doing this show
um their chinese stomach
medication so i'm gonna i might do that
later
[Music]
oh tears of the sun oh man i'm very i'm
very nervous
i don't know why i think i'm nervous to
meet you because i've been watching you
for so
long and like i'm a fan so uh
you remember go 90 and i remember go 90
i remember my vag i go all the way down
hell yeah that's tight
respect okay all right so we're just
going to go into it it's the back half
here
back after
so i get the sense that your creative
spirit is rooted in a deep abiding love
for
storytelling reading buckowski at age 11
and then of course you had early musical
influences like tom waits and jazz
legend chet
baker what do you mean when you muse
that embarrassment and humility
are major sources of humor and
creativity in general
when i was young i um i
i felt that i felt out of place a lot
and then i also felt
you know after my mom passed away that i
was always this kind of like
a symbolism of like sorrow of like of a
child that
uh you know his life is broken
and i didn't i didn't want to uh be that
symbol
and at the same time i realized that
they were people would laugh out of my
inadequacies so like when i was
embarrassed or when
i would humiliate myself or when i would
do things without really thinking about
them or say
saying crazy things that people would
often
be very amused by it those influences
that you talk about
it wasn't that like oh i'm like so
[ __ ] cool that i read charles
witkowski at 11.
my dad had a book of his poetry the
thing about bukowski
that got me like was that he absolutely
hated himself
in a lot of ways and he he knew the
circumstances of his life he knew that
he he just knew a lot of he was
self-aware in a way that i've never read
any author b and he was self-deprecating
in a way that
like it really like to right now it
makes me excited because when i read
that stuff
it just it self-awareness and
wallowing in something that you know
that you won't change that you should
i think is is so beautiful i've always
been more attracted to like
the the kind of the tortured experience
of things because i i
truly do believe that a lot of things
are born out of uh
um are born out of really uh bad events
sometimes
uh that's what shaped me
[Music]
all right the honey badger you know when
like um
like like a lotion i wanna say like
maybe a moisturizer
something that separates and it's been
it's like it's been like since high
school and it's like separated
i think that saved me here because i
think the honey badger had separated a
little bit like so at the top was just
like the nice oil
oh never mind wow oh wow oh okay
yeah when i when i'm in pain sometimes i
tend to yell so i'll move the thing
over so you don't get any reds on your
ears
so as the creator of nora from queens
and the author of a travel guide called
aquafinas nyc you've long repped the
city throughout your work
and recently there has been thinkpiece
after think piece after counter think
piece after counter-thinkpiece
new york is dead do you pay attention to
that trend and what do you think of it
new york is not isn't dead i don't think
i
i will say that new york is is
constantly changing
to the point where you know when i was
from when i was
young and that new york that i loved
was someone's version of a changed not
the same new york right
and i think that's that's the kind of
thing about well new yorkers and new
yorkers are always going to complain
about how much york is changing and new
york and new york won't stop changing
you know we're all going through
something as like a nation as a globe
once we're able to kind of see our way
out of that whatever
these thing pieces think new york was
it'll return to it
there's been a grassroots movement to
save businesses and in particular
restaurants that have been hit
especially hard by the pandemic
how intertwined is the food in new york
city to the essence of what makes new
york city great in your opinion
so intertwined someone has asked like
what's your favorite food city
and i think that you know my new york is
the city to prepare you
for all of those food cities so that
when you go to
you know like oaxaca or you go to to
india or you go to
singapore all these places like you you
kind of understand
the basic the bases because you had them
at some point you know
so yeah new york won't exist without it
it's not
it has to yeah it won't exist without
food culture it's not new york
[Music]
all right yeah yeah now
[Music]
yep that's what that is wow
wow
immediately wow
wow you know what that tastes like
i'm super into mukbang and there is a
a noodle with a very innocent looking
chicken on it
and it's not even chicken flavored but
uh
it's called like chicken bulldog it's
like a cheese chicken thing but this
specific noodle
oh wow how come it doesn't go away
wow i think if anything it just keeps
getting worse and worse and worse
so before you ever created a garage band
beat i know that you are somewhat of a
funder kid on trumpet
gaining admission to the highly
selective new york city arts high school
laguardia
and you know i think brass instruments
similar to maybe
the accordion or the bagpipes i feel
like sometimes people
goof on them you know they don't get the
respect that they deserve
for someone who has seen the light what
to you is most sacred about the trumpet
um what's sacred to me about the trumpet
is that it
carries your own voice through it so
you're able to
sing through it so your individual voice
is carried through it people can rag
you can rag on all you want but i'm
gonna blast you away
with the volume laguardia is often
called the fame school for its
formidable list of a-list alums that go
from al pacino
to jennifer aniston to nicki minaj was
that kind of setting
that environment with those expectations
was that a blessing or a curse for you
at that age
i think this is a story with a lot of
people and it's really a testament to
who you
are like are you gonna are you gonna
sing or swim because
i was like the best trumpet player in my
junior high school
but then like probably the least best
trumpet player in laguardia which
essentially vets the best trumpet
players out of
the entire city i think it could be both
i just kind of missed
having kind of a no strings relationship
with the trumpet rather than having to
practice all the time and stuff
all right aquafin are you ready to move
on
i does it know worse
it doesn't get worse
what's it called when your mouth sweats
oh drooling
duh there's no butthole on it so it's
like it comes out so much
i have but the butthole one sometimes if
you shake it just as
i'm gonna you know what [ __ ] it
ready are you ready i'm ready i'm ready
all right
yep oh you ever been so hot you're cold
yeah i get those i get those chills and
those sweats all the time
oh wow just part of me and me
so it's hard to overstate your meteoric
rise from
winning awards to red carpets to the
string of powerhouse films that you've
been in over the last few years
lulu wang the director of the farewell
said you sent her an audition tape that
convinced her to cast you
how much did you channel your own
experiences with grandma fina for that
audition 100 it was also like the beauty
at which
lulu was telling the story but also she
was my
what i think like a totem or an anchor
for me to get in the zone for me
for me to feel like the true seriousness
is like what what was
what what's at stake here um my grandma
i i it was only my grandma you know the
entirety of the shoot i think about my
childhood my grandma my mom first went
and my grandma kind of came in and
when i got sent that script i really had
just never imagined that anything like
it would come to me
sorry i'm just gonna dab my forehead i
never
thought i'd have to do that okay wow
yeah let's go i'm ready yeah [ __ ] yeah
okay
do you remember what bobby lee episode
did he shart
uh he might have more than sharded you i
vividly remember that that was the best
episode ever
i remember exactly where i was i
remember that moment
i remember everything about you you were
freaking out too
i remember you were like whoa like are
you all right
that sound when that hit it never really
hit the boom mic like it hit my ear in
real time
like it had a real sort of like flop
quality to it right
right right it did i'm replaying it
myself yeah
i'm not threatening anybody i'm not
did something just happen yeah hold up
hold on hold on hold on
ah
no oh did you hear it
[Laughter]
quality do it all right
[Music]
yeah i never been so hot and cold at the
same time
all right aquafina here we are
approaching the summit of mount scoville
and on our hike along the way boy have
we covered a lot of ground
from your films to your music to your
comedy but i want to close with a
tribute to one of your childhood
obsessions and that is the 1997 classic
film
airbud and believe it or not it's
actually spawned
something like 12 sequels and offshoots
how do you explain the connection and
impact that that 1997
cinematic masterpiece had on a young
aquafina
i couldn't have big dogs when i was
little we only had little we live in an
apartment we don't want to be
big dogs but i knew that the big dogs
you could train them to do all kinds of
they shoot hoops and all that kind of
stuff
one thing that the impact that it did
have on me could i ever own an airbud
would there ever be a movie about like
my experience than everybody because no
you'd have to recast the parents
to be asian i loved that movie i uh
and also homeward bound have you seen
home rebound
classic story about getting lost and
finding
your way back and you know what just
like the wings of
death how you can start off being a
comfortable place
things take a left things take a right
they zig
they zag you lose your way in the spice
woods but you know what aquafina
eventually you find the light and you
come out on top
and now there is nothing left to do but
roll out the red carpet for you my
friend
this camera that camera probably just
the one that you're looking at
let the people know what you have going
on in your life um
well right now uh probably i'm probably
gonna uh take a nap after this
please see raya on the last dragon which
comes out in theaters on march
5th um also watch watch breaking news in
yuba county which is also coming out
pretty soon i don't have the exact date
on that also um
this one this one here this one this one
this one don't don't just don't
don't
anyway thank you sean i'm a huge fan i
continue to be
after this yeah i hope i didn't i hope i
didn't do anything to fracture the
friendship
sending the sauces away if anything i
hope it's brought us closer
no you've helped grow the fanship and
the friendship and all that
so thank you
hey what's going on hot ones fans this
is sean evans checking in to say thank
you so much for watching today's episode
and i have an exciting announcement
a very exciting announcement a look at
us
look at us who would have thought not me
moment
that is right some of my favorite shoes
of all time
now in hot sauce red and then of course
we have the milky silky classic legacy
the spicified questions and the
refreshment inspired
classic legacy hot ones and reebok
going together like hot sauce and
chicken wings
the questions are some of my favorite
shoes of all time and i can't believe we
have a hot ones version right here
look at the details you have the flames
on the laces
you have the chicken on the back and
then you have a dab of hot sauce to
represent
the last dab and then check out the
scoville scale
1 million 990 000 scovilles 1996 that's
when the shoot came out
that's when i was running around the
playground at south elementary
with my questions on and here they are
on the hot ones table who would have
thought
and then of course you have the classic
legacy
milk inspired has the splash of milk
along the side
and then bill see if you can pan in real
quick on this
refreshments on the front the chicken
on the back pick up your parrot
reebok.com
hot ones reebok.com hot ones to get your
hands on a pair
spicy
[Music]
you